i love seeing an incredible story come
to an end
don't blink or you just might miss it
fans are getting a small taste of what
they can expect when the kissing booth 3
premieres later this year
hello like this is awesome while netflix
hasn't shared a release date or a
trailer for the third and final film in
the franchise
they did provide a sneak peek while
revealing their 2021
movie lineup that makes me so excited
netflix confirmed a third and final
kissing booth movie
last summer shortly after the release of
the movie sequel
the first flake premiered back in 2018.
hold on relax shelly it was just a kiss
it noah was it just a kiss
in a super trailer previewing all of
their 2021 movies
fan cl played by joey king giving a big
old squeeze to her bestie lee
played by joel courtney and she has some
fun in the sun with her boyfriend noah
who
of course is played by jacob ellerty i
love seeing an
incredible story come to an end the
kissing booth 3 takes place the summer
before
elle heads off to college and we'll
follow her as she grapples with the
decision to
a head off to harvard with noah or b
attend berkeley with lee you'll recall
the sequel ends with l
lying about getting into both colleges
i got waitlisted everywhere
berkeley and harvard
an earlier teaser for the third flick
showed elle secretly agonizing over her
college decision while trying to have
some fun with noah at the pool
but she puts those worries aside to
sneak off for a little romance with her
boo
yes i would like that very much yeah i
thought you might see you
where are you two going no wants to read
me poetry and tell me all about a speech
really is that what you want to go with
the on-screen love interest
previously dated in real life but called
it quits before
shooting the sequel and when eti caught
up with joey in july
she admitted that dating in the public
eye can be brutal
in this world everyone wants to know
your business
and what you're doing and um it's i
think it's it's very interesting when
you go through things
and um people feel like they are like
kind of owed an explanation
but i understand i understand um so for
me
i've you know publicly gone through some
things privately gone through some
things it's all about
finding your balance finding you know
what makes you comfortable
and um it can be it can be brutal but
you know also happy endings do come
to those who are you know patient
and joey jacob and their co-stars taylor
zaccar perez
and maisie richardson sellers teased a
third installment
before netflix announced it do you guys
i mean feel like there's more story to
tell with both marco
and chloe in a potential third movie
hugely i feel like they both finally get
you know
their feet off the ground and then it
ends so i think we want to do a third
film that'd be so fun
please like our fans loved the first one
so much
and they ultimately are how we got to do
a second one so
if they are loud enough about this one
about hopefully making a third one maybe
netflix will
i don't know grant has the permission do
you think that elle and noah
our end game yeah yeah why not i think
so all right
oh there we go yeah now we're making the
fan happy
you